what are you doing Oh it'sit's eggnog
yeah Merry Christmas was like something
no thanks I'm agnostic oh well fair
enough you know you know this time of
year makes me think of for their games
yeah pretty much I'm sticking you know
so many things happen in 2008 we should
do Wired's top 10 game-changing moments
of 2008 the trends and news stories that
like really need a big difference this
year it sounds like a good idea you know
coming in at number 10 of our top 10
game-changing moment of 2008 is a temp
and failure to buy take-two interactive
he was hoping to supplant the power of
blizzards world of warcraft and
activision's guitar hero being together
under one roof by acquiring 2k and
getting grand theft auto unfortunately
for EA take-two's shareholders didn't
like the deal and it fell through that's
bad news for EA but great news for
gamers less consolidation means more
competition in at number nine it's you
guessed it wee bit everybody said that
Nintendo was crazy a big box a huge
controller they have to stand on the
whole thing costs 90 bucks and and we
fit is an exercise game that's actually
more work than it is play but we fit is
actually on track to outsell grand theft
auto 4 it's not just a success story for
Nintendo it's proof that casual games
are big big business okay so Sony's
still third place in the console wars
but they did win something in 2008 the
war over high def movie format there
were two competitors Toshiba's HD DVD
and Sony's blu-ray of course every
PlayStation 3 includes a blu-ray player
HD DVD couldn't compete with the sales
of Sony's game machine until they called
it quits so the playstation 3 save
blu-ray now the question is can blu-rays
save the playstation 3 number 7 its
final fantasy 13 to xbox 360 yeah Square
Enix might be spreading the love around
in general a little bit more than they
used to back in the day when
only made games on PlayStation but the
Final Fantasy main series has always
been one console only so it was a huge
shock at e3 when square enix announced
that final fantasy 13 would be available
on playstation 3 and xbox 360 on the
same day in western territories it's one
of Microsoft's biggest victories in the
console war so far and it's proof that
things are really changing over there in
Japan number 6 Phil Harrison quit Sony
and joins Atari the retirement of the
father of the PlayStation ken kutaragi
was a pretty big shake-up at Sony but
nothing was more shocking than Phil
Harrison's departure Phil Harrison was
one of the founding fathers of Sony
Computer Entertainment of America but
even more shocking than leaving Sony he
joined Atari which was losing all of its
internal licenses and development
studios and even more shocking than that
he just might be able to use all this
industry powers to turn to taree around
he's even got the res creator on board
to make a music game for the week that's
probably the best thing Ataris done
since yards revenge the number five
game-changing moment of 2008 is when the
Beatles signed with rock band now
everybody knew after the success of rock
band that guitar hero was also going to
add drums and vocals setting the stage
for 2008 as the battle of the band games
who's gonna win we don't know yet but
harmonics just scored one major point
The Beatles yeah those beetles are going
to work exclusively with the makers of
rock band to develop a brand new music
game based on their music guitar hero is
gently weeping right about now number 4
micro transactions are no longer funny
we all had a good laugh when Bethesda
tried to sell us armor for our horse for
two bucks in Oblivion but what happened
next not funny gamers jumped on the
micro transaction bandwagon now you can
buy extra quest for fable or fallout 3
you can buy weapons in Far Cry 2 you can
even buy a t-shirt for your sackboy for
five bucks the days of heading to a
store and dropping 60 bucks for a
complete game yeah those are pretty much
over now they'll get you when you get
home to number three it's the Wii
in the DS smashing sales records
nintendo's wii and Portable Nintendo DS
are on track to be the number one and
number two top-selling video game
systems of 2008 but they also might sell
more hardware this year than any other
video game platform has ever done in the
history of the business yeah another
indication that casual gaming is here to
stay and in these troubled economic
times Nintendo's lower-priced offerings
might be exactly what consumers are
looking for in 2009 from sim games to
music games to platformers
user-generated content with the new big
thing this year will write sports
populated with millions of user made
creations littlebigplanet every day you
get a new dose of hundreds of player
made levels and even guitar hero world
tour has song creation tools the only
downside to all this user made goodness
copyright infringement that awesome God
of War level and little big planet
yanked Mario remixes or Zelda's Lullaby
and Guitar Hero yanked come on lawyers
let us have a little bit of fun and the
number one game-changing moment of 2008
is indie games finally coming of age you
know at the independent games festival
last year was a fun place to sort of go
and hang out and just check out some
indie games when he wanted to get away
from all the hustle and bustle of Game
Developers Conference it's this year's
Game Developers Conference the indie
games pavilion was the hustle and bustle
everybody was looking for the next big
indie hit after the breakout success of
games like portal you know we hear that
some of the IGF winners actually already
have publishing deals small team
projects like braid and audio surf or
capturing our imaginations and taking
time away from multi-million dollar
video games that were supposed to be
play and Microsoft's new community games
channel on xbox 360 which lets garage
developers upload their games and lets
anyone play them I mean that's huge that
is a brand new world for indie game
development and that's why indie games
are the biggest game changing trend of
you